why does bad grandpa exist it's very
simple my friends to put to rest the
rumors once and for all about there
being no more class in modern cinema bad
grandpa so bad grandpa's presented by
the Jackass crew you know in the Jackass
movies johnny Knoxville addressing the
old man make up and go around and just
mess with people it's that but an entire
movie based around that character well
that character and a little kid in this
movie actually there's a story to go
along with it that's not like jackass
please just get after skit they're
unrelated they do form a story around it
the story is this little kid has to get
to his deadbeat dad because his mom's
going to jail so the bad grandpa needs
to get this kid to his dad it's a road
trip jackass style how can you not look
forward to that this movie cracked me up
a lot of the bits had me laughing pretty
hard because it's amazing what we let
old people get away with johnny
Knoxville plays the part up perfectly
he's this old perv who's remarkably
racist and you let him get away with
that [ __ ] because you're like yeah
you're all the same you're old the movie
is just a really interesting social
experiment that's how I saw it it's
interesting to see what people will put
up with it's interesting to see what
people will turn a blind eye from I mean
this old guy is taking this kid
cross-country and he's saying [ __ ] to
the kid the kids saying things back him
it's obviously dysfunctional and these
people who are not in on the joke react
there was one bit it cracked me up these
people I mean obviously something was
wrong and Knoxville's giving excuses
like no no it's not what you think it's
this and they're like okay it must be
and it's not it's clearly he's gonna do
some illegal [ __ ] you can set you can
see the gears in these people's heads
turning where it's like if I just don't
say anything I don't have to deal with
it so I actually don't think it's bad I
think they got fired I really do think
they got fired at first the fact that
there's a story and they're in the car
talking to each other and no one's being
pranked but they're playing their roles
for you the audience it's unexpected so
you're like oh what's this then you fall
into it you're like oh okay it's cool
the moment you accept this prank movie
is more than just a prank movie but a
roadtrip movie of character bonding
you're like oh cool and it works for it
I tip my hat to this movie because they
optimized every situation imagine a road
trip every pitstop you making a road
trip and more because they're gonna make
more pit stops in this road trip because
if they have to entertain you but every
it stop is another opportunity to mess
with people and we get to enjoy it how
is that not great the biggest bummer in
this movie is the trailer showed too
much yeah the beauty contest scene
that's in the trailer it's like the holy
[ __ ] moment of the trailer it's supposed
to be the holy [ __ ] moment of the movie
- it's the last bit they do it's the big
closer but you've seen it in the trailer
and if you've seen the trailer like 21
times cuz you watch a lot of movies like
I do then you have seen the bit 21 times
does it make a bit less impressive it
just makes it kind of old at this point
I have seen that bit so much you can't
show your strong closing bit in the
trailer that's stupid
so it makes the movie look like he's
just hilarious and then it fizzles and
then it ends so like okay look Ken had a
weak ending that sucks ass for the most
part though bad grandpa was hilarious
Johnny Knoxville and this little kid
worked really well together that kids
really talented I don't know how that
kid keeps a straight face but he ruffles
with a lot of [ __ ] he ad-libs really
well - this kid's on his game you have
more variety in the Jackass movies you
have a lot more people doing a lot of
different [ __ ] back grandpa's ultimately
the same two characters pranking people
which is still hilarious so bad grandpa
is worth buying on blu-ray it had heart
to my friends where I live I did learn a
valuable lesson in this movie though
never ever ever ever ever ever ever call
a black dudes dick a tootsie roll to his
face that is clearly an offensive line
things are so bad grandpa have you seen
it what's your favorite prank they do in
the movie if you haven't seen bad
grandpa what's your favorite prank
you've ever seen whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]